here with Chef Curry himself Steph let's
get right to it this summer watching
your workout videos I'm still amazed on
how focused you are and how determined
to be one of the best in our game today
take me through your workouts this
summer I mean every year it's another
opportunity to kind of reinvest into
what you know kind of makes you great
and you know there's always uh just the
pressure
of kind of reasserting like who you are
every single year and redefining what
that is and especially you get deeper
into your career the work gets harder
and harder but it gets more rewarding
because you trying to extend your Prime
for as long as you can you're trying to
compete at the highest level like all
the things we know are important but um
you know I just try to have fun with it
too cuz as you know like double digit
years you get up there you know every
summer becomes uh a little harder kind
of to to manage just with the mils you
put on your body and all that type of
stuff so I'm just trying to balance all
of that still have fun with it still
push myself um to be ready for another
year when you're preparing for this year
your phone starts going off Phoenix is
doing this LA's doing this this team's
doing that what goes through your mind
that the West is getting deeper and
deeper um I mean I think if you look
back from the time we first you know
started competing for championships what
2014 15
like uh the the moves
become uh louder I think just from our
perspective because we understand how
many teams are trying to position
themselves to be in that conversation we
want to be in that conversation every
year we feel like we are um but we also
know we're built around a core that uh
has been doing this for a very long time
and so we're not going to have too many
big splashes but we feel like our team
is in a really good spot and that's the
way the league goes right everybody's
trying to get better whatever that means
for themselves and you know some teams
are taking big swings and big chances
and um big names are moving but the West
is deep the reigning Champs are in the
west so you have to go through through
Denver um and every team's trying to
chase so you know we're in that group
you mentioned your core you clay
Draymond how happy were you to see clay
finally have a clean workout summer and
that kind of prepare coming off an
injury uh I think it's big for him he's
you know a lot was said and and covered
around his comeback two years
ago uh obviously to help us win a
championship that year last year uh you
know he got off to a slower start you
know compared to his terms and his
expectations and I think to your point
he he spoke it into existence of how he
wanted to approach the summer and the
offseason to get um you know put himself
in the best position to hit the ground
running come come training camp so but a
guy
GP he's my it's good to have him back at
the beginning of the year not halfway
through the year but um but clay you
know in terms of everything that he puts
into the game um the work ethic that
he's developed over the course course of
his career for him to be able to do that
and not worry about his body um that's a
big deal you know he went through a lot
for two straight years um two plus so
I'm excited for him and again it's all
of our challenge to try to continue to
evolve as we get you know through our
careers to you know adapt to what it
means for us to be a successful team
this year and I know he's about that I
know this team will buy into the team
concept but I think the biggest question
the basketball World wants to know last
five minutes of the game how do you
figure out the final lineup with Chris
Paul being on the
team it it's a good question just cuz
it's something nobody seen in terms of
you know what he provides for you know
offensively and defensively his IQ the
way that he can kind of manipulate games
uh just with his decision making so we
have options and I know that's not the
answer people want to hear in terms of
what it's going to look like cuz I don't
even know yet um but it's the ability
for us to say okay we all know how to
play basketball we know um you know we
all have a competitive kind of streak
and we understand like everybody wants
to be out there everybody wants to be in
that closing lineup and that's how it
should be only five guys can play at a
time as the rules of the game um and if
we are going to be good if we're going
to do anything great this year if we're
going to be the team that we want to be
um we'll all buy into it no matter what
you asked to do and I'm going to try to
live you know Le by example on that
front I know CP will um but to kind of
Rush past the you know training camp
process and the feeling out process of
what that actually looks like that would
do us a disservice too cuz um it'll
it'll illuminate what that looks like
how much is important for you to get
number five the fifth ring it's
everything man like you know I've been
blessed in the game to win and uh I've
had a lot of amazing experiences
but it's the reason like you train as
hard as you do in the offseason it's the
reason you have the belief coming into
the season because nobody just wants to
Coast through their end of year career
and and just play meaningless games like
that's that's no fun at all I'm not
worried about the the Legacy piece of it
it's just more I understand how much how
much you're the best point guard or
magic best point that's that's up for
social media right that's all for social
media and clicks and the uh the never
ending debates that you can never prove
but to your point like just this is like
we want to be in a position and I want
to be in a position where you're playing
games that matter and you're winning
you're playing uh trying to chase
championships for as long as you can
because you know it's going to be over
at some point so that's why five is
important it's not for anything else for
the resume it's like playing basketball
to win and that Championship is about
that love you brother appreciate tell
you too man appreciate it yes sir man